xforce red cloud testing services ibm
api connect as a service on aws and the
2022 trust radius top rated awards all
on this episode of ibm tech now
what's up y'all my name is ian and i am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news announcements about ibm
technology
to kick things off this week i want to
take a look at the all-new xforce red
cloud testing services
now i know it sounds like a star wars
battalion but it's actually a new
offering from ibm security that can help
uncover and fix cloud vulnerabilities
and misconfigurations that may expose
your most valuable data to attackers
x-force red offers two types of cloud
testing services cloud configuration
review and cloud penetration testing
cloud configuration review assesses
public cloud instances to ensure secure
configurations protocols and best
practices are being followed
the team finds known vulnerabilities and
misconfigurations and ranks the flaws
low medium high or critical it then
provides a report of the findings and
recommendations for how to remediate
with the cloud penetration testing the
x-force red hackers the good friendly
kind of hackers go in and determine how
attackers may exploit misconfigurations
and other flaws in the cloud
infrastructure they then provide a
customized narrative of what they found
how they leveraged the flaws to gain
deeper access and what attackers could
do with the data
to learn more about xforce red cloud
testing services and how they can help
you check out the blog i've linked in
the description of this video
next up i want to look at the
forthcoming release of ibm api connect
as a service on aws cloud
as many of you know apis provide the
foundation for modernization and help
organizations build successful business
ecosystems by linking together
individual systems that contain data
ibm api connect provides comprehensive
intuitive and scalable api management
that helps enable organizations to
create manage protect socialize and
monetize apis across clouds and
on-premises
that's why we're thrilled to announce
the upcoming release of ibm api connect
as a service on aws cloud
starting june 28th ibm api connect will
bring the flexibility of these
comprehensive api management
capabilities to businesses located on
aws
to learn more hit the link below and
register for the webinar on june 29th
to wrap things up today let's take a
look at the 2022 trust radius top rated
awards
i think ari schenken our vp of
performance marketing said it best
peer-to-peer feedback is how customers
decide in 2022 it is an essential part
of the customer journey
i couldn't agree more and the trust
radius top rated awards use peer review
feedback to showcase the best software
offerings of the year
we're extremely proud that this year 19
ibm products across 41 categories
qualified for the trust radius top rated
awards
now i won't drone on and list every
single award here but suffice it to say
progress and customer satisfaction can
be attributed to ibm's continued focus
on our clients and ibm is honored to be
recognized in the top-rated awards
for a full list of all the products that
were honored check out the link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of ibm tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics i've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in tech now
you